that's Tiffany Gomez who went viral on
the internet for all of the wrong
reasons I'm telling you I'm getting the
off and there's a reason why I'm
getting the off now the quote crazy
plain lady is apologizing for the rant
posted on tick tock
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable thanks
for joining us here on Law and crime I'm
Anjanette Levy Tiffany Gomez was on a
flight that was supposed to leave Dallas
for Orlando back on July 2nd but those
plans changed after she had what seemed
to be a meltdown on the plane
I'm telling you
you can either Believe it or they cannot
believe it I don't give two
but I am telling you right now
after that airport police were called to
the gate and heard about a dispute that
took place on the plane between Gomez
and another passenger
it was a disturbance yeah
one officer boards the plane to check
out everything
Matt do you need anything
well she's from she's messing with TSA
we're probably gonna arrest her for
public intoxication Okay so
yeah
um still continuing to be a headache
then the officers were left to walk
through the airport to find Tiffany
Gomez they had her information from her
boarding pass and believed she was
likely intoxicated officers found the
man Gomez was accused of hitting the one
who quote wasn't real
no it's okay
why you are the part of the I don't know
what you who stuck into the in the phone
okay so I was just sitting right here
and she just got me here
[Music]
no are you okay you heard yeah
sure okay yeah okay
[Music]
okay
all my life so it's just gonna be like
it could take 20 minutes okay so that
also mean what does that mean it means
to uh to fight somebody to you know push
them
to bring some kind of farm bottom right
right does that make sense yeah
[Music]
you don't want to do anything about it
um
do you mind if I get your information
real quick
at the same time that the man is telling
his story to officers another officer
found Tiffany Gomez outside
no because we're your reports otherwise
I have made no physical contact with
nobody okay I've had it all in video the
whole entire time so
can you give us your touches around so
now I've touched I've had physical
contact with people
on that disturbance
now I get to go deal with that
but I'm going to keep it on video the
entire time then a second officer
approaches from a different direction so
what's your plan
where do you see what happens
well yes because obviously we just got
reports that you would talk to somebody
okay wait
assaultism
s
exactly how do you plan on getting home
you can't hang out here if you have no
business at the airport you can't be
here I don't want to be here okay
okay
I will gladly press request it right now
can I do that while I'm videoing you
probably not
so we weren't gonna think here why have
we not already requested
because I've been talking to my mother
about what's going on okay so she's
requesting she wants to she's going
through questions okay so exactly the
jumping that you
allegedly make contact with okay
okay
[Music]
I can tell your Art's having a bad day
we're not trying to make it any worse so
[Music]
in the box
it's been a little more than a month now
since that entire interaction and the
police body camera video is just now
coming to light and a seemingly contrite
Tiffany Gomez has posted a video on
Twitter hi everyone it's me
Tiffany Gomez probably better known as
the crazy plain lady which is completely
warranted Gomez in a scripted statement
apologized for what she did that day
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary I'm telling you
and there's a reason why I'm getting
I want to apologize to everyone on that
plane especially those that had children
aboard
can't imagine going through that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world just happened
we all have our bad moments
um
some far worse than others and mine
happened to be caught on camera for the
whole world to see multiple times
sorry trying not to sound like Minnie
Mouse then the apology took a different
turn Gomez said she's enjoyed some of
the memes but there's been a flip side
on the flip side it is very invasive and
unkind
and I don't know what I would do without
the love and support of my friends and
family I hope that I can use this
experience and do a little bit of good
in the world at the end of the Twitter
video Gomez posted that she's on a
journey to promote good mental health
and stand up against cyber bullying what
that means is unclear she posted a link
to her website that simply says stay
tuned for Law and crime I'm Anjanette
Levy